hey I'm Peter Ruben and I'm Kelly Ruben
this is Crosby split screen because
there's more than one side to every
story and every movie game every TV show
TV shows like inside Amy Schumer which
is now a few weeks into its third season
on Comedy Central and the sketch show
just kind of keeps upping the ante it
does yeah earlier this week it would
maybe the most kind of technically
ambitious episode that they've had yet
yes episode 3 which was 12 Angry Men
inside Amy Schumer it was kind of three
acts of sketch with just 12 guest stars
and really the question is is Amy
Schumer hotter or not you know for me I
like going to be a naysayer cuz I loved
the episode I loved the episode but it
is essentially the exact same premise as
the sketch from a couple of episodes ago
last couple day the one with Julia Louie
Dreyfus
and the dragon two women are allowed to
be on TV as long as they are sexy and
then yeah exactly exactly and my worry
is that she is there isn't all the kind
of incredible women in comedy right now
she's the most confrontational my fear
is that the premises may start to blur
together a little bit if you're hitting
the same target each time then I just
want her to kind of continue to push it
yeah I mean it's an important target to
hit though it's one of those things that
does come up within any industry that a
woman is in and I can only imagine that
it must be worse and stand-up comedy
like that's so male and like just with
every Jetley if she's ever in a roast
what are they gonna attack just how much
they don't want to sleep with her I
didn't want her to keep pushing it I
just that's all I'm saying I just want
her to kind of keep dialing it up and
making
thing more daring than them and I'm sure
she will you know she has a wide variety
of sketch top topics I know that might
be the one that we see the most
prevalently but she has approached on
their subject that's a fair point I'll
take that yeah and we hope you're
watching and we hope you'll continue
watching us so hopefully we'll see you
next week on another episode of split
screen